-I don't know how to sit.
-You did a great job.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You always overthink it.
-Yeah.
Did you overthink
sitting right now?
-Well, you know,
like when you're,
I don't know, filming anything
and they're like,
talk on the phone,
but make it look natural
and then you don't because
you're overthinking it.
-Yeah
-I just overthought sitting.
-Yeah.
You look pretty good sitting.
-Thanks, man.
-It looks like
you've done it before.
-I watched.
[ Laughter ]
-You've researched a lot
of tape and stuff and stuff.
-Lot of years of sitting.
-You're one of the best sitters
I've ever sat next to.
-I appreciate that.
-You're welcome, yeah.
-This is your talk show debut.
-Yes, sir. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm honored.
I'm honored that you're here.
-It's an honor to be here.
-Welcome.
-Yeah, first of many times.
You're in one of the biggest
shows in the world right now.
"The Night Agent."
People can't
stop talking about this,
but there's another role
that you played
that people can't stop
talking about.
And if you know
what I'm talking about,
But you were once
on the show "iCarly."
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Is that you?
-That is me.
-Yeah.
-It's hard to tell.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I think the whole premise
of the show
is it was hard to tell.
Yeah. What was it, like,
a bizarro world or what was it?
Like, You played Freddy.
-So I had my own idea
of what should have happened
where there's like a battle
for who gets to be Freddy,
you know, and the fakes
try to remove the real ones.
But they didn't like that.
It's Nickelodeon.
-Yeah, I know.
Of course, yeah.
What do you remember
about doing it?
-I don't remember much,
to be honest.
I forgot that this happened
until recently,
and everyone was reminding
me of it.
-Because the Internet
just loves it.
-Yeah. So I don't remember.
-You don't remember?
-It was fun, I guess,
as a kid.
-Yeah. And now it's having
a resurgence.
-Yeah.
-How long have you been acting?
Since how old?
How young were you?
-13 to 18,
and then I quit
for like seven or eight years.
-And you quit
because you just go
it's -- I don't feel like it,
it's not for me
right now or...?
-I just...
I think actors are really
insulated from reality.
And I think of all people,
actors should be the least
insulated people
because they got to, like,
portray real things.
And so everything sort of felt
like a pseudo experience to me,
like, as a kid where,
oh, you can be the fighter
And then not actually
hit anybody
or know what it's like
to get hit or whatever.
It just felt very fake.
So I quit because I was --
I didn't want to be depressed.
[ Laughter ]
-Good, good.
Good luck, buddy.
Yeah, yeah.
-And now I'm back.
-Yeah, now you're back.
Yeah.
You got a smile on your face.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But you can do so many things.
I was looking on the Internet
about the different skills
that you --
-I hope it was on
the Internet,
and you're weren't,
like, watching.
-I wanted -- Yeah, I'm --
I'm watching every move.
Yeah, but you can
you're -- you're skilled
at knife throwing,
archery, weightlifting,
professional fighting, drums...
-Amateur fighting, yeah.
-Yeah. Sorry.
I aided professional.
-I don't get paid.
-Drums, violin,
drawing, welding.
-Yeah.
-Wow.
It's fantastic.
-I don't have a social life.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, no.
But, I mean,
this is one of the other
things you just, I guess...
Did you just get a Master?
What do you get?
-Oh. So, yeah.
I got my DSWA
walling license,
so that's dry stone.
I'm a stonemason.
-So, you know, how --
how did you...
-So I have a trade.
I'm useful.
-Yeah, I know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes, you are useful.
Yes.
-Yes.
-You are useful.
But this is beautiful.
This is --
I'm so jealous of this.
I couldn't do anything
like this.
I couldn't do.
That's a gorgeous wall.
And when someone builds someone
a wall, it better be good
because it has to stand
the test of time.
-Yeah, I hope it does.
And that's sort of
the funny thing
is you're building
these things that, I don't know,
kind of put this business
in context because you're like
this will last way longer
than people --
than my show will last.
And then you go outside
and you're looking
at your wall...
[ Laughter ]
It's not really funny.
It's just sort of like --
-I think, again, you're being
a little hard on yourself.
-I think it's a good thing
because I think people
have so much ego about stuff
and to look at a wall
and be like,
wow, if they lost their Wi-Fi,
they couldn't watch my show.
But this wall, like,
serves a purpose
and will be around.
It just...
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dude, you're...
You have to come back
on the show.
You're one of my favorite
guests we've ever had.
You're fascinating to me.
I agree with you.
That wall will last for...
-It should.
-Yeah, absolutely.
-I don't know.
-No, I --
I think you got something.
Let's talk about
"The Night Agent,"
because this is --
it already got picked up
for another season.
-We're still on one.
-Well done.
-Thank you.
Thank you.
-How does it feel?
Because I know you do the show,
you work hard on it,
and then it comes out and then
everyone's watching and you go,
"Oh, this is kind of cool.
People are talking about this.
I didn't know who would, like,
if it would catch on
or be as big as..."
It's giant.
-It's always nice
when people enjoy things,
but especially
when it's like your art.
But for me,
it's a little uncomfortable
because I do pen
and ink illustrations
and stuff and, like,
that's me.
That's from my head.
This is so, like,
collaborative.
And when you're done
and you're working, you're done.
And then everything that happens
that everyone else sees
was so out of your control
and out of your hands
that it's sort of like people
compliment you
because society sees it's you,
but then you're like,
but I didn't edit
the stuff.
I didn't -- I didn't do anything
other than my job.
So it's, like, it's just
uncomfortable for me.
[ Laughter ]
Like --
-This is the realest interview
I've ever had in my life.
It's unbelievable, fascinating.
-I remember I had
a camera operator.
-Just keep going.
Keep going.
-There was a camera operator
buddy of mine.
-Tell me about it.
-And I just...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think this is --
-I have a good --
I have a good fix for you.
-You do?
-Yeah, let me
fix you real quick.
-You have a -- you have
a good fix for me.
But -- so you have...
-So, -I'm looking at the camera
operator and I'm like,
wow, this job does not happen
without a camera operator.
And in the same way, it doesn't
happen without a focus puller.
So it's like we're all
sort of working together,
and then the end product
though,
everybody's like, "Gabe,
we love you."
And I'm like --
-It's a team.
-Yeah, it's a team thing.
It's like on a ship -- and this
is how I think about it.
If it's a ship,
like those old Greek ships
and everybody
has an oar in the water,
like I have my oar
and I'm doing my job.
And as long as I don't screw up,
the boat's going to get
where it needs to go.
But we all have to orient
to the captain's authority.
And it's not like --
if you have ego,
then it's like the ship
doesn't go anywhere
because it's not my job.
-Well, you make a turn
in the one way
because you're rowing
too hard on that side.
-You get frustrated because
you're the, you know,
the guy and you take your oar
out of the water
and then it's this
self-fulfilling, like...
-Yeah, and then I see you,
I nudge you, I go,
"Look, he's not even rowing."
-Yeah, exactly.
And the captain's like,
"What the hell?"
And you're like, "Well..."
-Talk to Larry.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Gabriel Basso.
-Gabriel Basso in
"The Night Agent."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-Guys, I think
I see a way down.
Come on.
Take my hand.
-Okay.
-Come on.
-Oh, my God!
-[ Groans, coughs ]
-Are you okay?
Peter?
-Your turn.
-I'm not jumping down there.
-I'll catch you.
-You'll catch me?
-Yes.
-That's crazy.
-Crazier than waiting around
for your friend? Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Gabriel Basso.
-What clip was that?
-I quickly wanted to show
what an amazing
artist you are with
pen and ink there.
This is a picture of you.
-Cant' really tell.
-It's a dark photo,
but this -- you --
That looks like Keanu Reeves.
-Yeah.
-Is it?
-Yeah. He -- he commissioned
a piece for me, and I...
-That is Keanu Reeves.
-Yeah.
-Hey, cool.
-What's funny about
this picture too,
is like the context of,
Hey, you do pen and ink art
and you can't even see the art.
And it's like, That's Keanu.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, so...
[ Applause ]
-Get out of here.
[ Laughs ]
Can you come back
on the show Monday?
I want to keep
talking to you.
You're fascinating.
You'll work it out.
-You have my number.
-Yeah.
-Thank you very much.
Gabriel Basso.
"The Night Agent" is streaming
now on Netflix.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.